you adrift on the sea for three days and
certainly it was very difficult to know
during that time whether we gonna
survive
ah God you look at Homs and Aleppo in
Syria Vietnam look like after the war
I am the child of Vietnamese refugees
who arrived prior to 1975
oh my family together with 40 others
escaped from Vietnam on a very small
fishing boat to the villa Indonesia it
took 14 days my mother made all of us
keep a backpack and in it was an address
of an aunt in San Francisco just in case
we got lost from each other my dad
couldn't afford to tell everyone that he
had sent me off he said that you know
wherever you go remember who you are
sunny lei leis it's not just your name
it's my name too
and your grandfather's the name so don't
mess it up my parents did not let my
grandparents know that we like we were
escaped and I could see that my mother
never forgive herself for leaving her
parents behind it's too difficult for me
to there was no looking back
certainly there was no looking back for
us at that time whenever I hear that the
Vietnamese resettlement was the last
global resettlement of its kind it's
frightening because it's not like there
are no more refugees I have this fear
that there are millions of people out
there who don't have the resources that
we benefited from and that I feel we
gave back to when I saw the picture of
the little boys on the beach in Turkey
that is really bring back a lot of sad
and horrifying memories no one would
undertake that decision lightly
no matter what how is it you can hold on
to two children and a wife and try to
steer about at the same time if you look
today I'm in Syria Libya Iraq
Afghanistan those people when I wouldn't
have left hadn't been for regional
conflicts of which the US has a handle I
truly believe all the nations that
support the war
other nation that responsible and should
have the more obligation to resettle all
those refugees the visas get people in
but the resources that's necessary all
of that somebody got to calculate
quickly and really give a solution based
on what we can afford or what we think
our conscience can afford